[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's see if chris sims is territorial
pro football talk live co-host and of
course football night america analyst
two sports star in high school how would
lebron do as an nfl player if i put him
at tight end chris
i i had a hard time thinking he wouldn't
be a really good tight end i mean if
that's what he decided to put all his
interest in
and go that route yeah i would think
he'd be able to pull that off you know
the one thing that i always come to with
guys like that you know even though hey
gronk right he's six six and a half six
seven lebron's six eight plus yeah the
the issue those guys fall into dan is
their knees will be hud just head hunted
that's really the only thing that i
would ever be concerned about i know
lebron james can play titan and do that
just nobody he's just gonna he's so long
and so
you know
just high cut wasted that's where it
gets dangerous for those guys because
every safety and linebacker is going to
go right at those knees and that's where
it gets dangerous but you have football
players
they played basketball in college and
then they come into the nfl that doesn't
happen the other way around chris where
somebody plays college basketball uh or
college football and they go you know
i'd like to play in the nba
no no you're right it does not it does
not happen i mean usually hey it's you
know nba got some freaky guys and
there's a lot of with my and dada and my
dad and i have this conversation a lot
we'll go watch good high school
basketball games and see a guy that's
you know a 6-6 center you know in a high
school basketball game in new jersey
right and he's a high and then we go and
look at each other and go man he's he's
blowing it he'll just be another guy in
basketball but he could be a tight end
or if he decided to put weight on he'll
be an unbelievable left or right tackle
in the nfl he's wasting his time trying
to play center in the nba you're right
you see that more i think on that side
than vice versa do i think there's like
some receivers and dbs and tight ends in
the nfl who decided to like oh i want to
play nba basketball i could do it i
certainly do you know i look at russell
westbrook in the nba and go man if he
wanted to play a receiver and be one of
the best in football back in high school
he could have done that too so uh i do
think it's the two sports with the most
athletic freaky guys uh as far as sports
are concerned how would shaq have done
in the nfl
i mean he'd be uh
he'd be unbelievable
it's almost like it's inconceivable i
don't even know what to think like he'd
be impossible to run around if he was a
left tackle like how could you ever get
around him he's got good feet and even
if you think he got the edges arms are
like six feet long he'd push you by guys
so i i i guess the biggest thing with
him is could he get down into
three-point stands and react to the
quickness and everything of that nature
like again now shaq is a really big
human 7-1 right 330 pounds in his career
again that's really big and strong but
let's not forget in the nba and the nfl
you got a lot of guys who are six four
and six five and 300 pounds and got a
lower center of gravity and i do think
we'll be able to push him around maybe
more than we think just because of the
way he's built but you know he could
probably do it he's such a freak of
nature all right any concerns if you're
a cowboys fan after what you've seen
through the first three games
no i don't think i got any concerns it's
all positives i think at this point
right here you know the big thing is the
the defense
it's of course the made an unbelievable
turnaround under dan quinn they cause
turnovers you know they're certainly
better but the offense is the the the
story that they're an elite offense
they they like you saw last night
they can change the way the other team
has to play because they can put such
pressure on you on the offensive side of
the ball a lot like the chiefs or the
bucks or the rams it's hard to match up
with them you want to play man-to-man
you're not going to match up with all
those receivers in a tight end
man-to-man somebody's going to be a
mismatch and then now we're seeing the
run game get going as well you know that
to me and a two-headed monster at
running back with power and ezekiel not
a whole lot of concerns i mean they're
gonna they're gonna win the nfc east and
they're gonna be in the playoffs that's
for sure
yeah
i just wonder about mike mccarthy this
is this is back-to-back games now where
we've
you know do does every team have a clock
guy to help the head coach chris
most teams do yes i don't know if i can
say to every team but i would think that
yeah most you know i i know most teams
at least a lot of the coach or head
coach friends i'm with have that guy
there to kind of be there be the guy to
look at you should challenge this hey
think about these timeouts here yeah
that was a blunder at the end of the
first half i think that's where you're
going with this right i mean you know
hey it's 20 to 7.
again you have another chance to put one
of the elite units of football on the
field in your offense who has not been
slowed down at all in the first half and
you could put a team away and i was
saying to florio bringing this up
earlier today i mean how many get how
many games every week do we look at a
game and go this team's dominating but
they let this team hang around and now
they're going to lose the football game
and to me yeah mccarthy is a little bit
of a liability with some of that clock
management stuff three weeks in um
you all in on the rams
i'm all in on the rams i am a hundred
percent i i you know dan i picked the
rams to go to the super bowl i did not
expect it to look like it does this you
know this this good this quickly that's
for sure but yeah fastest defense in
football really well coached got studs
that can make plays and like we were
just talking about on the offensive side
of the ball you know with the the
cowboys match up mismatches all over the
football field stafford in a real
offense with talent around them and a
good offensive line yes the rams are
going to be here to stay they're going
to be one of the top teams in football
what would you say to chiefs fans
oh
i would say
you know don't panic it's one and two it
could easily be three and oh i mean it's
mistakes and mistakes by them alone that
are costing them football games i mean
that's really the bottom line you know
mahomes no look pass stupid i mean just
throw the ball to the guy he catches it
he's gonna run in for a touchdown he'll
be up seven nothing you know tyree kill
fumbles the next drive clyde edward
hillaire fumbles the next drive after
that you know the two blunders at the
end of the monday night game against the
ravens so they got to you know just show
teams that they can be patient why teams
play these prevent you know we're not
going to let up big play defenses and
show that they can have the patience to
just be surgical like let's say you know
brady and the patriots and 20 and you
know his whole career where you just go
we can't just sit back and play umbrella
defenses they're going to pick us apart
it's going to be a 10 play 80 yard drive
for a touchdown they just got to show
they can do that that'll bring some
teams up again and then you'll start to
see more big plays down the field with
tyrique and company
buccaneers go to new england
yeah what do you expect
well the buccaneers are clearly a class
above the new england patriots right now
and i just i guess
i think new england can be a pain in the
butt in the football game and hang
around for a little bit
but i just don't know if their offense
will be able to keep pace as good as i
think the patriots defense is that's a
real good defense you know the bucks are
they're special on that side of the ball
brady's still got a laser for an arm
they can protect them
and of course you know with all the
weapons they got i just have a hard time
thinking that you know new england's
going to be able to with a rookie
quarterback keep pace and go on 10 plays
80 yard drives consistently against the
bucks defense you know that's the issue
with the patriots right now there's just
no big play maker there's nobody that
scares you and you know mac jones isn't
gonna execute the offense to the
capacity brady did in his prime or
anything like that so they're kind of
finding their way they haven't run the
ball as well you know i think they're a
pain in the butt because belichick's
gonna have a great game plan but i
ultimately think the bucks win touchdown
10 points something like that chris sims
pro football talk live co-host and
analyst on sunday night football
how did we come to the conclusion after
three games that ben
roethlisberger has done
well
by watching the games i think that's why
what did people expect though well
that's what i listen dan i tried to tell
people last year and i got eviscerated
by people in pittsburgh when they were
10-0 and i didn't tell big i didn't put
big ben as one of the 10 best
quarterbacks in football i mean they
eviscerated me oh what an idiot sims hot
take bullcrap no just because you're
10-0 doesn't mean you're quarterback's
one of the 10 best players in football i
mean come on you know and it's been more
of a disaster than i would have thought
it would have been dan you know again
yeah they haven't been able to run the
ball you know the protection's been
solid but not bad and to me it's just
bad decision making poor throws like
unrealistic
uh
unrealistic expectations of himself in
the pocket that he thinks he's gonna
pull off magic at times i just i'm i'm
i'm shocked by how badass looked you
know at the quarterback position there
in pittsburgh
the situation with chicago the jets the
jags with these quarterbacks
to me this just illuminates
why you were in the position to be able
to take a quarterback because you're not
a good team
and you know the bears got justin fields
a little bit later in the first round
than you know what the jets and jags did
they're still a bad team just because
you went a little bit later doesn't mean
they're they might have a little better
defense i guess but that offensive
line's not good jacksonville's offensive
line is not good and now you're having
people saying hey you know you should
sit these quarterbacks you're going to
stunt their growth and like what what
changed from the beginning of the year
everybody wants the new quarterback in
there and i always say be careful what
you ask for because whoa i mean
like what do you think happens in these
three situation is there any chance
trevor lawrence
maybe sits down for a game uh they don't
have a legitimate backup for zach wilson
and justin fields do you put him out
there because the line isn't any good
well listen if if if they get broken
these guys and it's like week six and
you're like oh no
they're overwhelmed like then you picked
the wrong guy i don't know what else to
tell you i mean it's starting
quarterback in the nfl they've they've
dealt with some adversity but i think
your points real like too many people
are trying to write the headline already
about these guys and their careers and
we're three weeks in yeah they're it's
they're not good teams the jets got
nothing on offense that scares you no
legit game breaking receiver the run
games average at best pass protection
has been way below average just go by
the look of what you see of the players
don't hold them to like mahomes or tom
brady or matthew stafford standards
right now they're gonna make mistakes
like you said the support system's not
correct you know so yeah within that i
i'm more in just how does it look trevor
lawrence made a few plays in the game
last week where i went damn there's only
a few quarterbacks in the game that
could make that throw with that play yes
i know he had some dung rookie mistakes
that go along with it but he looks the
part he'll learn how to play and what he
can get away with in situational
football and that goes with zach wilson
too i mean again what yeah what do
people expect there there's nothing like
you you could put brady and mahome on
the jet homes on the jets they're still
going to be 0-3 they're still going to
be 0-3 it does not matter it's not them
so to me it is just about continuing to
give them confidence protect them don't
fall in the trap of oh we're down we got
to throw at every play now and and try
to make the game look respectable no
there's got to be a fine line there of
protecting your guy for the future
protecting the organization but at the
end of the day i like the look of all
the guys i do and i am always in favor
of playing them get their lumps next
year they'll be a different guy and
there'll be a lot to learn from from
this year
well they're quarterbacks because of
their success that it makes it tougher
for those that follow like justin
herbert yes sure just justin herbert
looks like a veteran
yes well dan i would argue like i always
do with everything else looks like a
veteran but come on got to take over a
team last year that was really a playoff
caliber football team that just screwed
up every big situation that is possible
clock management end of the game field
goals missed whatever but you know they
haven't changed their team around much
this offseason other than then they got
two offensive linemen that certainly
helps out justin herbert but it's still
the same roster there so yeah he was
fortunate to get in a position where a
team with philip rivers and the year
before
was drafted underperformed so they were
better than their draft you know
placement mahomes of course he got to
take over the second best team in the
afc and they traded up from 27 to 11 to
go get him and he got so he has that
benefit yeah some of these other guys
don't and you're right people just got
to put that in perspective a little bit
and just calm down and they'll get the
right support around these guys and
you'll see why they're picked number one
and two and and that's what people have
to understand or at least in the back of
their mind keep reminding themselves
because dak prescott goes to a dallas
team that had one of the best offensive
lines in football right let me start
there we saw when mahomes had no
blocking in the super bowl he was
average right tom brady can be average
if you put pressure on him every one of
these quarterbacks there's not a
quarterback that's played where you go
hey got a terrible offensive line we're
under the super bowl like it just
doesn't happen and
justin herbert has a great offensive
line dak still has an elite offensive
line uh drew brees survived because he
had a good offensive line with the
saints brady always had good protection
with the with the patriots and the buck
i mean
this it's not rocket science you know
you know that if you have a good
offensive line chances are if i put
justin fields on
you know
put out you know throw out a team if i
put him in new england instead of mack
jones is he more successful absolutely
because he has a better offensive line
there but you know 100 i just think
people get caught up in the why isn't
our guy you know the next mahomes
mahomes with the jets as you point out
they'd still be winless yes they would
it's just everybody you know we've
gotten in this era of just quarterback
that's the reason win or lose and that's
it and you know i know you've heard me
say this stuff before
you know but come on yeah hey
quarterbacks can certainly cover some
holes oh the team's not playing their
best today
but he's still awesome so he'll make up
for that that's what a great quarterback
does he doesn't make a crapola team look
amazing that's not that's not possible
you got to have some sort of support
system there and you know i just oh
these are what i always go back to these
are my lines when we get into this jared
goff went to the super bowl i think
everybody sees now he's not a top 20
quarterback in football never was never
will be they went to the super bowl nick
foles won a super bowl and beat the
greatest quarterback of all time it
wasn't because of nick foles the eagles
were really damn good
peyton manning on his last leg 2015
super bowl i mean come on it was like
let's just hope peyton doesn't mess the
game up i mean that's where we're at i
don't like saying that he's you know
arguably the greatest quarterback ever
too but you know again it is about the
football team and and we're in this era
right now where it's just quarterback
quarterback quarterback quarterback and
if we win it's the quarterback if he
loses the quarterback and there's just
more to it that drives me crazy all
right yeah i'm glad i got you fired up
good yeah you did yeah
uh great to talk to you as always thank
you chris you're the man dan tell all
those guys i said hello there
yeah okay hey guys chris says hello
hi you jerks your jerks that's what i
wanted to say you can say that yeah all
right hey you jerks i'll see you later
all right that's chris sims pro football
talk live co-host nbc sunday night
football